- We're back, baby! Cosplay, part two!
- So, we watched a bunch
of anime and decided
that we're going to go with
Sailor Moon characters.
- Pretty Guardians already
sounds like a great band name,
so we're just going to
take that literally.
- Because it's like
all these strong women.
We can be strong women.
- We decided to make our
concept really unique
by turning the Sailor Scouts into men.
- Not try and make fun of it, but to have
an honest portrayal of
how bad-ass they are.
- Cosplay is all about
passion and creativity,
so we're taking a lot of our passions
and creatively mixing them together.
- Punk rock.
- 80's glam.
- Ned's wife.
- Meets dudes Cosplay.
Have you seen a lot of post-apocalyptic,
80's glam, punk rock band
Sailor Scouts before?
- No.
I'm Olivia, and I am a cosplayer.
- When we were watching Sailor Moon,
we realized we kind of fit
the character archetypes.
- Zach is a tiny nerd.
- Sailor Mercury.
- Keith is a big ol' man, who loves
shoving food in his big ol' mouth.
- The Sailor, Jupiter.
- Ned loves love.
- Love, love, love, love, love.
- Sailor Venus.
- Eugene's Sailor Mars,
because he's sassy.
- She's kind of a bitch.
- I feel like I'm her already.
We just did not like Sailor Moon.
She's very annoying in the first season.
(buzzer)
- If we show up with half-assed costumes,
people are going to
judge the f*** out of us.
- I thought cosplay was
all bought costumes.
- No, they make that s***.
- I'm gonna get frustrated. Whoops.
- I'm ready to do whatever
it takes to make the
best costumes in the history
of me ever making a costume.
- We're gonna need some help.
- [Voicover] The Try Guys
Try Cosplay, Episode Two,
the Try Guys Make Sailor Moon Costumes.
- My name's Linda Le,
and I am a Cosplayer.
Something like this
took me about 700 hours.
- What?!
- 700?!
- What are the basic things you need
when you start construction?
- Generally, we use things like worbla.
- Wo-wo-wo-worbla...
- At least know how to
sew a straight line.
Hot glue is really great for foams.
- Yeah! Hot glue.
- You guys should definitely
feel some pressure.
- Alright, let's do it.
- Boom, boom, boom, boom.
- And Anime cut.
- What you need to start
patterning your tiara,
you cut out your shape, and you get this.
- Madame Jupiter. Perfect!
- Dude, dude, dude, no.
- Then you start cutting it out.
- This is a very basic Cosplay
accessory anyone can make.
- Trace. Just trace. You
already f***ed it up.
- I f***ed it up.
- This is already not fun.
- Hot glue the ray's detail.
(pained yelling)
- What happens if you touch it?
- It doesn't have to be perfect.
- Ah, that's a lot of extra.
- When that's all done--
- Hello?
- You'll have your face tiara. Yay.
- Boob bump.
- Our energy was waning, so
we thought boobs would help.
- So now it's time for actually
constructing your tiara.
- He's been injured. Go!
- Go, go, worba-worbla!
- For people that don't
know what worbla is,
it's thermal plastic. With
heat, what happens to it,
it gets really soft. Almost like pasta.
- Tiara-ravioli.
- Kinda heat it.
- Bend to my submission, pasta plastic.
- You don't want to heat it too much.
- She said that we were good. Turn it off!
Yeah, you're gonna burn it!
- And then you're gonna
take the second piece.
- Now I'm really mad!
- And you kinda put it on top, right here.
- I've got a mustache. I know we're doing
better than Mercury and Venus.
(screaming)
- Don't point it at me!
- As you can see, it's already
coming out pretty perfect.
- Can I give you an Asian
household experience?
- No.
- Yeah, do better.
- Okay, this is good.
- Shwing!
- Moooo, I'm a planet girl.
- We're f***ing awesome at this.
- In Cosplay, the sexiest
thing is confidence.
So, if you're wearing your costume,
you're really proud of it,
and you feel really bad-ass,
it kind of shows, in the
way you stand, pick, dance,
how you interact on
stage. It's really cool.
- When you see guys as
Sailor Moon characters,
do you like it?
- That's awesome! It's so good.
- It's empowering for women.
She is the first superhero.
They're one of the first ones for girls.
- And it's all about
different types of women.
- Being tall, I always got
made fun of when I was younger,
but it just gave me strength to be me.
- It's being yourself in a team
that helps you win the day.
- Now, we're actually
gonna start making the
Sailor Moon bows.
- I can honestly say I've
never made a bow in my life.
- That's a version of a bow.
- In college, on winter
breaks, I'd sit around,
and while we're all hanging
out, I'd just be sewing.
- Well, that's like what
lonely, weird people do.
- It's about the process.
- No, it's about the end product.
- So, when she's cutting out the pattern,
I'm going to be threading the needle.
- Whoa.
- My mom taught me how to sew.
- Come on, baby.
- You pop it.
- Lock it.
- And twist it. And
then you slide it. Boom!
That's your knot, that's all you need.
- But there was a needle.
- F***, I forgot the needle!
- I would trace it first.
- So you do that, I'm
gonna try this technique.
- Are you already sewing?
- Yeah.
- How do I get the...
- When you're hand-sewing,
you want to make sure
that you're going to be sewing
in between these framework.
- I didn't get enough string for that.
- Boom!
- This is gonna take too long.
You wanna more to hot glue?
- And then we close the
opening with the whipstitch.
- Am I doing this whipstitch correctly?
- Probably not.
- Oh!
- How does mine look?
- How do you know where you're
poking through? There it is.
- Glue is really a good way to do it,
because then it doesn't take much time
and you can go make a burger instead.
- Then, when you turn it
inside-out, look, you have--
- Sleeping masks. Done.
- A seam.
- I can't believe I've been
doing this for like an hour,
and I have so many injuries. Ow!
- Fold the center to create the pleats.
- I made a bow tie for a mouse.
- How does mine look?
- All you do with the ribbon,
is tie it right in the middle
and wrap it that way.
(manly grunting)
- Oh damn.
- Okay, look.
- Mistakes were made.
- I'm really proud that I made it myself.
That's what matters.
- Also, we got the authentic experience,
because our clothes are off. I mean.
- This stuff is really
meticulous. This must take forever
for someone to make an entire costume.
- This chaos was fun, but
if we're going to bring
the good the goods to Animex--
- We're gonna need to take our time.
- We've got a lot of work to do.
(fantasy music)
(peeing loudly)
- Were Eugene and Keith
better at making bows than us?
- Maybe.
- Yes.
- But were we better at ribbon dancing?
(slaps ribbons around)
You tell us.